the start of spooky season is right
around the corner but first our favorite
streaming services need to let go of
some titles to make way for new content
and Netflix is no exception here are the
movies you won't want to miss out on
before they leave Netflix in October
2019 the brilliant minds of Steven
Spielberg and Stanley Kubrick come
together in AI artificial intelligence
the 2001 sci-fi drama Kubrick began
developing in the late 1970s venturing
to adapt Brian Aldous short story super
toys last all summer long into a feature
film in 1985 Kubrick teamed with
Spielberg to continue crafting the
project when Kubrick handed Spielberg
the directorial reins a decade later he
ran away with it what ended up on the
silver screen was the unique story of a
childlike robot named David played by
Haley Joel Osment whose ability to love
and abandonment by his adoptive parents
set him on the journey to become a real
boy
it's one part The Adventures of
Pinocchio one part B Wizard of Oz and
one part exploration of a future post
climate change world it's also got Jude
Law as a male prostitute named gigolo
Joe so there really isn't anything more
you could want from AI a couple of
businessman Scott
with two equally mind-boggling sci-fi
horror sequels having come out in the
last three years it can be hard to
remember where the Cloverfield franchise
actually began it started in 2008 before
Dan Trachtenberg pulled a last-minute
twist in 10 Cloverfield Lane prior to
Netflix a surprise release of the
Cloverfield paradox with the original
found-footage thriller held by Matt
Reeves Cloverfield takes its name from
the fictional case in the movie known as
Cloverfield an incident in which an
enormous parasitic creature and a horde
of smaller monsters run rampant through
New York City killing people and
destroying the city presented as video
clips that members of the US Department
of Defense recovered from a camcorder
located in what was once Central Park
the film follows a group of friends as
they attempt to evade the monsters and
make it out of the Big Apple a lot
spoiler alert
not all are successful in that endeavor
Cloverfield will remain on Netflix until
October 1st the stoner movie that might
define all stoner movies
Pineapple Express will sadly be leaving
Netflix before you know it until that
time comes however squeeze in one more
viewing of the buddy action comedy
centered on a lazy stoner named Dale his
Dazed and Confused dealer Saul and his
supplier red as they flee from hitmen
and gangsters after witnessing a drug
lord and a crooked police officer kill a
man in cold blood
pineapple expresses silliness is what
makes the David Gordon Green directed
film so enjoyable and is maybe then
better by all-in performances from the
whole cast particularly Franco who
nabbed a Golden Globe nomination for his
work as Saul and a wonderfully quotable
script from Rogen and his longtime
creative partner Evan Goldberg only
reason I started selling pot is so I
could put my Bubbe in a nice retirement
catch a ride on the pineapple Express on
Netflix until October 1st for horror
lovers October is the time to catch at
least one of the films in the scream
franchise at least once per week get a
head start on that annual tradition by
working backwards with screen for the
2011 franchise closer that takes place
during the 15th anniversary of the
Woodsboro murders from the original 1990
it's movie well I guess today is the
anniversary kids directed by slasher
film icon West crape scream foresees
Sidney Prescott returning the Woodsboro
with her publicist Rebecca Walters as
part of the tour to promote her new
self-help book Sidney gets a lot more
than she bargained for of course as she
soon becomes a suspect and a number of
killings things go from bad to worse
when the masked killer Ghost Face begins
calling Sidney's cousin Jill and
threatening her life a Sidney and Jill
attempt to crack the case
so to do Woodsboro sheriff Dewey Riley
and his wife Gale weathers Riley it's a
fight against time circumstance and
traumatic history to rid Woodsboro of
Ghostface for good and Netflix
subscribers have until October 7th to
find out how it all ends directed by the
region filmmaker morten tyldum and based
on the Andrew Hodges written biography
Alan Turing the Enigma 2014's the
imitation game tells the incredible true
life story a british cryptanalysis Alan
Turing who worked as part of the British
government's cryptography team during
World War two and decrypted the thought
to be unbreakable German codes
transmitted by the countries and nygma
machine throughout the course of the
film it's revealed that Turing is gay
which is punishable by law in England at
the time and complicates Turing's
personal and professional lives the end
of the imitation game will stir even the
steel iasts of people leaving little
question as to why the film won an
Academy Award in 2015 or why critics
have praised it as quote a moving
tribute to an extraordinary man the
imitation game is available to stream on
Netflix until October 29 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]